and now we arrive in Sussex County New
Jersey and we're in New Jersey
this is not the Jersey Shore this is
Inland Jersey I think I am closer to
Manhattan than some parts of Brooklyn
time wise but it really feels like I'm
in Idaho
for these opening looks we wanted to go
very Jersey girl in my mind I'm like
okay so I definitely want like Snooki
inspired hair we're gonna go animal
prints for all of us I immediately think
like what else makes me think Jersey
girl all I can think of is giant boobs
a common designer I was like can we
please order the biggest breastplate you
can find and breastplates are like these
silicone rubber plates that give the
representation that you have real boobs
so they come all the way up to your
neckline and then you just like make
that garment to cover the blinds after
matching your skin tone from a distance
it looks like it's real that's the
illusion of it so we found a breast pump
plate that was Z cups so I had the only
set of knockers as I was running around
in this beautifully patchworked snake
skin vinyl dress I mean when I say it
was so fitted to my body it curved and
hit every Notch because it doesn't
stretch at all it's actually
anti-stretch because it's stiff
imitation leather and you know of course
I had my jewelry adornments I had a
giant snake head clutch my hair was
pompadord and then long and beautiful
with some nice jewelry in the hair a big
giant necklace giant jewels on the arms
I mean just glammed up trying to be City
girl but in New Jersey so very like high
Glam in the middle of nowhere was the
goal
I am a joysy girl straight up from the
shore came over to North Jersey to hang
out for a little bit of time so yeah my
ass a little big of course I love
awkward now my hand's going to be tall I
love gold so I have a chain in my hair a
chain across my neck because I have this
nice charm bracelet and I love leopard
print so a little bit of a mid-drift
they have a long legs I bring a mini
skirt and a pair of golden pops probably
ended a couple of marriages that day
walking through that car show
so I'm wearing a pair of gold strappy
heels very tall I look like I'm next
like these toy cars they're like up to
my like hip right here as I stand over
the car I really had a great time for
this look I had a charm bracelet with a
bunch of bobbly charms on it I had a
matching purse to go with it to have my
headband I have a claws necklace I have
my earrings but I also in Dragon like
why I'm so used to drag I'm like I guess
it's a normal this is my long lost
sister
the key things that really stand out to
me in this look first of all the hair it
was Jersey I called Gloria from wigs and
Grays and said baby for the hair on this
one I want you to look at the recent
photos of Teresa giudici getting married
quaff layered to the Sky hair down on
the side I said that's what I want and
baby that's what she gave me the dress
we wanted to make it something fun we go
with this look one shoulder out and I
love the cutout that's right here with
the corseted piece that was very key to
the salad because it was very snatched
in but at the same time it was still
exposed which was just brilliant and the
fabric itself had a Sheen and a shine to
it so it just wasn't flat it was like
and I love a good so I said Diego the
dress is lovely what can we do to make
it extra so he came up with this design
that had like these gold rings and from
each of the Rings there were like these
ostrich feather also like box Tails but
they weren't fur they were ostrich
feather and found this one boa that was
the perfect coloring of gold and black
and he just chopped it up and made all
these little things to go so when I walk
in baby she got the Rings Rings Seven
Rings like Ariana Grande cannot miss out
on the jewelry beautiful pieces and then
also the shoe baby gold is Grand I was
walking ladies and gentlemen how are you
doing tonight
this performance we come together and
it's a celebration at the end the design
teams came up with these Angelic
costumes that looked absolutely
beautiful the theme with here was Angel
we look like beautiful Christmas tree
toppers we look so great and we're in
these gowns with these Wings these Halos
Diego and then found this gold fabric
that even Lady Gaga used in a costume of
hers from her most recent chromatica
ball tour so it's this gold reflective
beautiful fabric that just flows and
pops on the stage it has the beautiful
Design Elements and and the wings I was
thinking I told him baby Celine Dion I
remember that dress that she wore the
white with the big cute sleeves that was
the inspiration for this one when the
Angels come out baby we give the
experience
laughs